cet enseignant dit avoir été victime de
profilage racial
exaspérée d'être interpellé par les
policiers de repentigny
il a installé une caméra à bord de son
véhicule à la casse
tu peux pas mentir alors c'est mon
témoin il en a aussi acheté une à son
fils de 18 ans puis qu'est ce que vous
espérez avec fait le seul espoir c'est
que il me faut de l'apc dont il fait
partie des voix qui s'élèvent pour
réclamer des changements au sein des
corps policiers une sérieuse réflexion
québec a créé en décembre dernier un
comité de travail pour moderniser la
police et améliorer les liens de
confiance avec la population
on va rencontrer des experts ou des gens
qui ont une expertise pointue sur le
profilage racial sur les interpellations
policières
on va rencontrer les groupes également
les groupes concernés il aura un mandat
très large puisqu'il se penchera aussi
sur les organismes gravitant autour des
corps policiers comme le bo é
l'upac et la commission de déontologie
policière
la commissaire en déontologie
s'interroge sur l'encadrement des
interpellations policières
ce qu'on observe c'est que il ya
certaines règles de droit qui donne des
pouvoirs discrétionnaires très important
aux policiers en matière
d'interpellation en matière
d'interception et l'absence de balises
mon avis est un facteur de risque
un rapport final devrait être émis dans
un an des organismes communautaires
comme le centre de recherche action sur
les relations raciales soulève déjà
quelques réserves
il aurait aimé voir davantage de civils
c'est une approche très exclusive presse
que c'est une forme d'élite la
population pour laquelle les services
police existent pour protéger servir les
groupes socio économiques ne sont pas là
françois du cac va plus loin au moins
j'y crois pas
il est encore marqué par son expérience
la rage l'acquis
qui m'habite encore la charge ce comité
de travail évaluera aussi les budgets la
formation des policiers et surtout le
maintien de la confiance du public tout
en conservant l'indépendance de la
police